[Musique]
gilles bayle maubon jour bonjour
monsieur carouge candidat donc aux
élections municipales et communautaires
dans la commune de sainte-anne vous êtes
âgé de 48 ans pourquoi on parle de votre
âge il bel mots parce que vous étiez
déjà candidat en 2014 il y a 6 ans dont
vous aviez 42 ans
c'est assez rare pour le souligner un
jeune de 42 ans qui s'engagent en
politique
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire par
rapport à sa banque le nombre d'années
n'attend pas en fait la compétence quand
on est appelé à servir comme tête de
lice ou comme premier magistrat d'une
commune
on n'est pas seuls on est entouré d'une
équipe donc il faut pouvoir faire
confiance et déléguer et c'est important
que un genou qui apporte un vent de
fraîcheur de dynamise mais on a on
attend des jeunes en fait qu'ils
prennent leurs responsabilités
voilà alors quand on est jeune on va
globalement dire les moins de moins de
50 ans quoi voilà c'est ça voilà alors
en 2014 gilles bayle mots vous aviez
recueilli 13 % des suffrages soit 368
voix c'est pas c'est pas gilles bayle -
c'est la liste la liste l'algo devise
est conduite par gilles bayle m'ouvre
tout à fait mais c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance nous journalistes à la parler
des têtes de liste mais c'est vrai que
votre équipe donc votre liste avait
recueilli 13 % des suffrages soit en
soit c'est très important monsieur rue
j'ai besoin l'oublié souvent ça quand on
est tête de lice que l'élection
municipale est une élection de lys tout
à fait chaque membre de la lys est
candidat et c'est à l'issue des
résultats que le conseil municipal lui
et lille au maire est souvent les mères
et c'est le cas de sainte anne dans
l'exercice de leur prouvant de oublie
qu'il a fallu un moment qu'il aille voir
qui se fasse aider et ensuite dans les
décisions
il oublie de concerter d'écouter
d'entendre et c'est ça la difficulté
tout à fait vous avez raison et souvent
c'est vrai que nous parlons nous
qu'on les têtes de liste mais souvent
nous indiquant aussi aux listes par
exemple dans les débats qu'ils peuvent
désigner de leur tête de liste ou un
autre colistier et souvent la liste
désigne la tête de liste mais elle peut
envoyer n'importe qui d'autre ça peut
être même le dernier entre guillemets en
position sur la liste est autorisée peut
venir débattre s'il le souhaite ou si
elle le souhaite qu en tout cas
d'aujourd'hui alors jeu comme on n'a que
cinq minutes
j'aimerais que vous parliez quand même
de vos projets et puis du regard que
vous portez sur la ville de sainte anne
après les les six ans passés mais en
2014 vous aviez le soutien plus ou moins
affichée d'alfred marie jeanne est ce le
cas en 2020
sylvain 2014 c'est un contexte
particulier est attaché parlementaire du
député du sud
donc le président jean philippe miller
alors oui fait faire donc le président
avait tenu à venir me soutenir à titre
personnel ce contexte du gym donc alfred
marie-jeanne oui ce contexte a changé
on sait mon prix c'est mon président
parce que je hais directement c'est bon
président puisque je dirige un organe
satellite de la ctm mais pour l'instant
le mouvement qui porte la lit ce qu'on
appelle un nouvel élan pour sainte-anne
et créant notre ville on avait demandé
officiellement matt soutient pas
d'investiture à quiconque absoute chez
personnes sur la liste des inscrits dans
aucun parti
c'est vraiment une citoyenne après
plusieurs mandats de garcin malsa sainte
anne a connu une nouvelle gouvernance
durant ces six dernières années avec
l'équipe de jean-michel j'ai mieux mais
est-ce aller mieux pour autant à sainte
anne à votre sens avec cette nouvelle
équipe
ben le constat il est là jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de plan local
d'urbanisme
donc le plus qui définissent un document
de planification qui définit la vision
territoriale qu'on a de la ville on a
pas de règlement local de publicité on
n'a pas de salle de fêtes on n'a pas de
bibliothèque
il manque un certain nombre d'outils
pour permettre aux jeunes et aux plus
anciens
de d'avoir les conditions de leur
épanouissement et de bien-être
alors vous avez reproché au cours de ces
six de ces six années là l'acquis de
cette mandature qui va s'achever vous
avez reproché à jean michel j'ai mieux
et son conseil municipal d'avoir pris la
décision de porter le taux de la taxe
d'habitation de la commune de 12% de 12
08 % exactement à 23 95 % donc une très
forte augmentation de cette taxe
d'habitation et vous dites que c'est des
choix qui touchait les administrés et
les contribuables sainte-anne elle les
plus vulnérables ça a été terrible
ça a été cinglant la taxe d'habitation
du jour au lendemain
arrêtez augmenté de 100% 100%
personnellement j'étais à 800 euros je
suis passé à mais c'est en raison de de
dettes contractées en fin d'une
situation occasionné dites-vous par
l'ancienne équipe 1 celle qui avait
précédé monsieur j'ai mieux l'équipe de
manière à deux garçons elle sait tout
qu'il y avait des recommandations qui
ont été édictées dans un rapport de la
chambre régionale des comptes qui
préconisait un certain homme de
solutions pour remédier la solution la
plus facile c'était la poule l'équipe
actuelle étaient simplement d'augmenter
mer ont parlé à l'époque de la taxe de
séjour
d'autres solutions étaient émises alors
il nous faut terminer rapidement votre
proposition est essentielle qui
symbolique de votre liste pour
sainte-anne
ben c'est une nouvelle recette fiscale
au travers de l'aménagement de la baie
de sainte anne donc une zone de
mouillage organisée ou permettent
d'avoir une nouvelle recette et
éventuellement peut-être que
nous sommes en train d'étudier sa dès le
vote du premier budget si nous sommes
élus by cbc cette taxe d'habitation qui
a appauvri et cette année merci gilles
belleau d'avoir répondu à nos questions
dans cette émission ça aux cadis spécial
municipal réalisé par adele qui dit
merci
[Musique]